one thing we wanted in the gameplay for
WWE 2k15 was a new sets of control to go
along with the new pacing of the matches
bring in you know any any game once it
wears a console transition it can be
difficult the one thing that the
designers really wanted to do was
revolutionising involve his game one of
the things that we realized is that the
games to Dave had somewhat of an Arkady
feel to them I've been planned and work
on these games for a lot of years you
know fundamentally the characters may be
different but they all play the same and
that's one thing that's always stuck in
my craw but now you know what it comes
to the xbox one and ps4 those shackles
are off so we started looking at things
like pacing and flow and like how does a
match start what's the middle feel like
I wanted to end feel like there's a
really good build-up of momentum and
excitement of course of a match there's
that moment in the beginning where
they're testing to the route you'll
begin to their chain wrestling you know
side headlock you know cool transitions
here and there to kind of gradually
build the audience into the match before
these are getting to their signature
offense we switched to a more cinematic
camera it focuses in on the characters
faces it's Randy Orton's you know with
the one putting the hold on him you see
that he's fighting for that extra low
you know torque I'm happy to say that we
finally been able to implement that and
this year's featuring it's gonna it just
change the game so as part of that we
rethought everything from animations
controls how you interact with the
people how fatigue sets in and to do
that a big part was actually shooting a
lot of animation working with visual
concepts we have been no captain like
crazy you know let me tell you when I'm
not in my office i'm at the mocap studio
getting all the latest moves entrances
the most of we're getting are just
simply amazing wrestling video games
aren't anything
animation data and so we brought the
game up to our own to KML caps to do and
have shot an immense amount of animation
over six times more animation that was
shot in any previous year and that's
going to help us really kind of bring
this new experience to life Oh seeing
the way the game is coming together on
next-gen is really impressive and as a
fan of the series and as a fan of
wrestling we've really hit our stride
with this game and as beautiful as this
game looks it's the gameplay that's
gonna keep them entertained and playing
this game for months years on end all
that hard work the long hours you know
it's all worth it once it's out there on
the shelves and the players you the
chance to experience it for themselves
and that's what we're in this for you
know as a fan of wrestling the fan of
double w/e that's a feeling like no
other it really is